-You know, one of the things
we've seen happen,
sort of the last month or so,
is Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
has proposed this
70% marginal tax rate.
So, you know, and then,
you know, people --
So it's the money you make
over $10 million gets taxed.
-Yeah, you get to have
your first $10 million
taxed like normal people.
-Yeah.
-After that, you got to pay
a little more.
And 70% of the country says now,
in a Fox News poll, by the way,
that they support her plan
to tax at the 70% rate
those over $10 million.
-And what do you think
that shift has been?
'Cause I don't think it would
have been 70%
even five years ago.
Is it the stories you were
just talking about?
Is it that people see their
infrastructures crumbling
and people are also buying homes
for $200-plus-million?
-It's all of that, but it's also
that people realize
that this myth that we were
raised on,
the Horatio Alger story that
anybody can make it in America.
Anybody could be a millionaire.
Anybody could be president of
the United States.
Well, we already --
well, we know that one's true.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, that one -- that's
definitely true now, yeah.
-But I think people
now know that, no,
because everybody is living
from paycheck to paycheck.
Half of the country does not
have enough money
in their bank account tonight
if a loved one passed away,
they don't have the money to fly
across the country
to go to the funeral.
The majority of Americans have
$400 or less available to them.
That is -- That's the majority
of our country.
So if they have an emergency
or something happens,
people can't afford it.
That has to change.
And I'll tell you, the rich,
the Howard Schultzes
and the Michael Bloombergs,
they better get a clue
because they are tone deaf
to the fact
that people have had it.
And I think people -- that's why
they support taxing the rich.
They support -- They see other
countries have free healthcare
and we are still paying
through the nose
and going through
all this rigmarole.
This has to stop.
And I hope -- Look, we've got
good candidates who are running.
Some of them are running
on this, you know.
I would also add, again,
if I were running --
And I'm saying if 'cause I heard
the other night,
you said on the air
no one has announced.
-Right.
-I'm not announcing tonight.
-Thank you. I would love you
to save that for another show.
Thank you.
-Yes.
But it should happen here.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Just out of courtesy to you.
[ Laughter ]
And a vast appreciation that
the American public has for you
and what you do every night
on this show.
-Very kind of you. Thank you.
-So thank you for that.
No, no, no. It's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I would -- Yesterday, they
reported the U.S. Postal Service
lost $4 billion last year.
They're talking about
eliminating the postal service.
No, if I were president, I would
keep the postal service.
I would give the mailwomen
and mailmen a job every --
at least every Friday,
they would deliver two joints
to every mailbox in America.
-Oh, wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Compliments of
your federal government.
-Yeah.
-And you know -- and just two.
We're not talking just --
-Right.
-Country won't work if everybody
is completely stoned.
But just two.
And it gives the postal service
a job.
I would try to think of things
like that to do.
-I think that's a good platform.
I want to talk --
Last time you were here
was right before the midterms.
-Yes.
-And I'll admit,
there was a little pessimism.
-Yeah.
-You were fairly critical of
Nancy Pelosi,
particularly her optimism
going into the midterms.
So not only was her optimism
borne out,
but how do you feel about her
and the handling
of the shutdown?
-I feel the same way
everybody feels.
She kicked his ass.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was amazing.
You know, many of us --
what is she, 78?
Many of us have had
a 78-year-old grandmother.
If you have one
that's really feisty
and really that puts her [bleep]
kicking boots on...
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know
if I can say that, but...
No, listen, she -- I was very
skeptical, as I am of anybody,
any politician, anybody
in a leadership position.
But since the election,
she has --
I mean, look what she --
she put Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and Rashida Tlaib,
our first Palestinian-American
in Congress, from Detroit.
She put them on the government
oversight committee
that's going to be one of
the impeachment committees.
-Yeah.
-She put them on
the impeachment committees.
That's -- I thought,
"Wow, okay."
She got the message of
the November election.
She's doing what
she should be doing.
I think it's very powerful.
The thing with Rashida, too,
to put her on --
Remember on election night,
she went to that party
and somebody filmed her with an
iPhone saying, you know...
-Go for it. Just tell them
in case they missed it.
-She just went up to
the microphone and says,
"We're gonna impeach
the mother[bleep]"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And everybody --
everybody was like,
"Oh, my gosh,
why did she say that?
Now she won't get
put on any committees."
And then what does Pelosi do?
She puts her on
the impeachment committee.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! I'm not dreaming, right?
-No.
-I'm awake. I'm with you.
-There's a lot
to keep our eye on, obviously,
in the coming months,
and please come back soon.
It's always just such a pleasure
to have you.
-Thank you very much.